- We're doing the book
tour and all of a sudden,
I get this email, that the Huffington Post
is saying that George W. Bush
plagiarized some of his book.
I'm like, "What's he talking about?"
Because, I knew that he
and a former speech writer
had worked on all of it together.
Like, "What are they talking about?"
So I read it.
I'm like, "Oh my gosh."
So this reporter for Huffington Post.
Wrote that in Bob Woodward's book
from like three years ago,
there's a passage in there in which
Bob Woodward quotes somebody,
who was a source close to the President,
who said this about the Iraq War.
Therefore, they said that that
(laughing)
that George W. Bush,
who had then written that
- I got it.
- In Decision Points, that therefore,
he was plagiarizing Bob Woodward.
I was like, "Obviously, he's the source
"close to the President, is
the President, you dumbass."
Sorry, can we say that on here?
(upbeat music)
- Hey, I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin Report.
Reminder everybody.
Get all our videos and audio
podcasts, absolutely ad free
and early at RubinReport.com.
More importantly, joining me today,
is the host of the Daily Briefing
on Fox News, Dana Perino,
finally, welcome to the Rubin Report.
- I'm so glad to be here,
we've been wanting to
do this for a long time.
- We have been wanting to do it.
We wanted to do it in person,
which is why we never did it via Skype.
But these freaking pandemics.
Is there anything worse than a pandemic?
- I mean it really did get in
the way of a lot of things.
- (laughs) It really did, so clearly,
you're not in studio at the moment.
- No.
- You are at home
and you've been kind of sharing,
you're trying to, I think do something
similar to what I've been trying to do.
Just kind of like share
your life a little bit more.
Your dog, what you're
eating, what you're cooking,
all of that stuff, in
the midst of this thing.
How is life, in the midst of a pandemic?
- Well life is good, right?
That we're here and that we're busy
and that we're working.
Life for me, I have to say,
I just don't have complaints,
or room to complain.
I try to live my life
with a lot of gratitude.
Then you go through something like this,
where you see what other
people are going through.
Sometimes I find myself
kind of holding my breath
and I realize that it's because
I'm really worried about,
well people's health, number one.
But I also am worried
that all of these people,
who are now having to ask
for government assistance,
where they never would have done that,
in their life, like they'd rather die
than ask the government for a dime.
Yet here, the government has had to
force people to not work.
And force them out of jobs
and now they're in a position
of having to apply for unemployment.
The government is trying to be generous,
but it's also the government and it's hard
and it's lumbering and it's just difficult
and so, whereas things
for us, are pretty good
and actually, I kind of
needed this forced pause,
because I was so over scheduled,
and trying to please too many people
and doing too many events
and dinners and things.
So the fact that I've
had time to reconnect
with my husband and I've
cooked more in three weeks
than in probably
(laughing)
22 years, because,
- And I like
- We're in the city
- that you put
- And it's easy to--
- the pictures.
You put pictures even
admitting some of these things
are experiments and they seem to
be working.
- Yeah (laughs).
Yeah I made, I got, so I have a Peloton.
One of my favorite instructors
is Hannah Marie Corbin.
I read an article where she talked about
what she eats in a day.
She recommended this cookbook
called, "Oh She Glows."
It's a vegan cookbook and I'm not a vegan.
Grew up on a cattle
ranch, so I'm not a vegan.
But, I know I need to eat more vegetables.
So I've been making some
recipes out of that book
and Peter likes them.
I like them, so I made
sweet potato enchiladas,
that felt like a big accomplishment.
- But Dana, have you taken
my advice that I gave you
on your show last week and
started growing Romaine
out of the butts
(laughing)
of other Romaine?
Have you done that yet?
- I have thought about that so many times.
(laughing)
I am going to try,
the butts of the Romaine.
The thing is, okay so my
day starts before six a.m.
It ends at nine p.m.
So, I've literally been
house bound for three weeks
and my husband, who
normally works from home,
he's done any of the
errands that we've had,
mostly going to the
grocery store or picking up
from local restaurants that we support.
So I haven't been able
to get the Romaine butts,
but I'm going to.
- But you're going to.
All right, fair enough.
So I like that you said
this thing about that
you needed sort of this unforced break.
Do you think a lot of people
are suddenly feeling that?
Like, just the way life is
and how fast everything seems to move
and social media and
the 24 hour news cycle
that you're well aware of,
that we suddenly got
this break and of course,
it's not for a good reason,
but that basically, if
you're okay right now
and you've got a roof over your head
and hopefully you have a couple bucks,
that there really is an
incredible opportunity
to kind of look at your life
and look at the world a
little bit differently.
- Absolutely.
If you read any,
anyone saying like, "Well what do you
"really want in your life?"
It's that people feel over busy.
I made a New Year's resolution
that when people said,
"How are you doing?"
This was a couple years ago.
That I would stop saying, "I'm so busy."
Because, everybody is so busy.
Everybody is trying
and striving and doing.
Nobody says, "Oh I'm
fine, totally kicked back.
"I get eight hours of sleep
a night, everything's good."
Everybody has stuff.
So I stopped saying that
a couple of years ago
and that was a good sort
of mental shift for me.
But I know it in myself.
I have a very hard time
saying no to opportunities
that come my way.
Everything is amazing.
Especially like in New York City.
"Would you speak at this event
"for this wonderful charity?
"What about for this veteran's group?"
I can be out week nights,
every single night of the week
and then trying to catch
up on life on the weekends.
What I've realized is that,
having to tap the breaks because,
we have to all do our
part in this pandemic,
it's been actually really good for me
and I don't have,
I know that I can't hold
on to this completely,
when all of us return to normal.
But I would like to figure
out a way that I could
hold on to a little bit of it,
because, it is better for me.
A lot better.
- Yeah, well it's interesting,
it's one of the reasons
why I like doing your show,
because, even though you're
doing informational stuff,
you're doing like the daily
grind political stuff.
There is this other feeling
that I think you have,
that a lot of shows kind of miss,
which is that there's something
that's going on in the world
at all times, that doesn't have
to do with politics exactly.
I think for you guys,
one of the cool things for me,
over the last couple years,
is I've gotten to know, I would say,
you, Greg Gutfeld, who's
a good buddy of yours
and Tucker Carlson specifically,
it's like when we watch you guys,
there's something a little bit different
about watching someone on cable news,
than on the internet.
Like it's almost like, "Are
these people actual humans?"
I think you've been able
to now show that window,
like, "Oh, there's a human here.
"Here is the dog.
"We're real people."
That actually
- You know--
- has been nice during this.
- You know it's interesting,
I give Greg Gutfeld a ton of credit for
actually bringing me along on that,
because, we started The
Five, in July of 2011.
Before that, I'd been the press secretary
and you know, that's a
pretty serious job (laughs).
(laughing)
Even though
I was in the public eye,
I didn't do a ton of personal things,
like I would never,
well we didn't have
Instagram or Twitter then.
So, I didn't really share my life,
'cause I thought, "Who would care?"
Well then we start doing The
Five and we would be asked,
"What do you think about this?"
Almost always, I was
instinctively giving the answer
as if I was still the
White House press secretary
for George W. Bush.
At one point, Greg said,
"No, what do you think?"
It was about drug legalization,
marijuana legalization.
I've never smoked pot.
I'm not into it.
I have a very unpopular opinion.
I don't think it's a good idea.
But I realized, I just froze.
I had never given my personal opinion
about anything out loud.
He pushed me a little
and teased me a little
and made it okay for me to,
it was kind of just more be myself
and not have to be the press
secretary, so much anymore.
So I get asked in an interview sometimes,
"Is there something that
people don't know about you?"
I'm like, "Nope."
Like it's been 10 years,
we've been doing The Five
and I was on Red Eye
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Before all that.
There is pretty much nothing that
people don't know about me.
So Greg actually really helped with that.
Then especially on The Five,
we take the news seriously,
but we don't take
ourselves that seriously.
Life can be sweet and God
meant for us to be joyous.
I really learned that from
President George Bush too.
We worked very hard, but we were always
celebrating the joys of
getting the chance to serve
at the highest levels of government,
for the best country
the world's ever seen.
- Yeah, so all right, let's
back up to that for a second.
So for the people that don't
know, you just referenced,
but you were press secretary
for George W. Bush.
That means you were the person.
I remember watching you,
(laughing)
back in the day, you know?
- Really short hair.
- You were up there,
(laughs) yeah and you were answering,
you were answering, or at least
to the best of the ability
of a press secretary, answering
a lot of tough questions
related to foreign policy and the economy
and all kinds of stuff.
Can you give me like some
insight into what that job
was like then, versus maybe how it is now.
I mean Trump barely has
to use a press secretary,
'cause he's just kind of out there.
Then the networks now,
CNN doesn't even cover
those things anymore.
You guys cover it, but how that sort of
has changed over, you know,
it's been about what, 20
years or so, 15 years.
- What it's interesting,
in January of 2009.
So January 20, 2009, the
Bushes turned things over
to the Obamas.
I was there for the last day
and then Peter and I left for Africa.
We went to South Africa
for a two weeks vacation
and two weeks volunteering
at a PEPFAR site.
I really wanted that time
to reset my priorities,
reset my marriage, reset my brain.
To get ready for this transition.
But I think back on that
and I didn't even have
a Twitter account, at that point.
If you think just, that was 2009.
Think in 10 years how things
changed so dramatically.
And you think about the Obama campaign,
that absolutely smoked the
Republicans on social media
in 2008 campaign and then,
in 2016, President Trump realizes that
he can talk directly to people
and he was very comfortable with that.
I don't know if George Bush ever was.
Sometimes I laugh and think about
writing a book of Tweets
Bush would've sent (laughs),
which, probably would've been
(laughing)
would've been pretty funny.
- It's actually a great idea.
- But it has changed so much.
Like now I will say this.
I think for the country, briefings
from the press secretary,
I always tried to turn down
the temperature in the room.
I thought, "Why are we fighting?
"I'm here to give information,
"you're here to illicit information."
I always remembered too,
that those reporters
have a job to do.
Part of my job as press
secretary I believed was,
protecting their right to
have access to the government.
But here's the other thing.
I truly believe that a press briefing,
a daily press briefing,
forces a White House to
have really good process.
Because if they know that
the press secretary's
gonna have to go out there
and she's gonna have to
answer these questions and that means
you better call her back first,
if there's problems and
the policy isn't settled,
everybody needs to get on
the phone and get it done.
Another thing I used to do was,
let's say I was, we were at
war when I was press secretary.
So things are all so different.
But let's say something was happening
and it was a national security issue
and somebody within the government
suggested I say, such and
such answer at the briefing.
Well, what I did, because I
was a reporter by training is,
I would double check and triple check.
So I had my deputies and I would say,
"Gordon, can you call the
National Security Council,
"see if this is what they say.
"Tony's gonna call DOD.
"You call the CIA.
"Let's meet back here in 20 minutes
"and if everybody has the same answer,
"I'll say it at the podium."
And if we don't, then I would go to the
Chief of Staff's office and I'd say,
"We've got a problem here,
because everybody's not settled
"and we have to get this
right, because people's lives
"are on the line."
So, in that case, I feel
like forcing good process
is really good, but,
everything's changed so much.
Who knows if it'll ever go back to being
a daily press briefing.
No, the President, oh he just finished,
you know he--
- Well he does them.
- (laughs) He does them now.
I think he's starting to enjoy
it, in the briefing room.
- Well he's having a hell
of a time in there, clearly.
I mean from the little bit that I can,
I don't have time either
to watch these huge things
in their,
- I know.
- In their totality,
but when I watch them,
I'm like, "Yeah, he's
actually having fun."
But that sort of gets to what
I wanted to ask you about
just sort of the general way
we talk about presidents.
So it's like I remember
during the Iraq War
and you being up there and all the things,
I lived on the Upper
West of New York City,
the most liberal place on Earth.
Outside Zabar's they'd
have the book tables
and every book was George
W. Bush is the devil
and evil and all of that stuff.
Where now, the media
because he's not Trump,
they sort of treat him like a nice guy.
He's also a little older.
He paints now, so he's kind of
(laughing)
good now and Trump
is the ultimate evil.
Do you see that sort of
always churning through
like every 10 years,
where the media takes someone they hate,
now they're good, 'cause
they have a new bad guy,
and that these pieces will
always sort of shift around?
- I have a great story for you about that.
Marlin Fitzwater, was the press
secretary for Ronald Regan
and George H.W. Bush.
So for eight years.
He was the press
secretary for eight years.
I joke with him that
- That's a long time.
- He could never have
done that in the age of social media, but.
He told me that, well actually
I invited him to my house
in October of 2008.
I invited all of my staff
from the press room.
I made them all read his book,
one of the best books ever
written in Washington D.C.,
as a memoir, it's called,
"Call the Briefing."
By Marlin Fitzwater.
It's fantastic, his
storytelling is spectacular.
So he came and we had a little book club.
And, he delivered a message to all of us
and he said, "I know you're feeling like
"your boss is really being
dragged through the mud."
Our approval ratings were terrible.
This is right after the financial crisis,
as you can imagine.
He said, "Let me tell you
a story about in 1992."
In January of '92, they had lost, or '93.
They had lost to Bill Clinton.
He said it was so mortifying
to lose to Bill Clinton
and he said, "When we left that day."
He said, "I had my head
was hanging so low,
"because I thought no one
will ever, ever understand
"and see what a great man
George H.W. Bush was."
Well, that changed.
You know time has a way
of changing perspective
and 43 used to say, when I
would prep him for interviews
toward the end, I said,
"Sir, they're gonna ask you
"what you think your
legacy is going to be."
He said, "Look, you know,
last year I read three books
"about George Washington.
"And if historians are still
analyzing the first president,
"then the 43rd doesn't
have a lot to worry about
(laughing)
"'cause he'll never know."
And he would point out
that Abraham Lincoln died
thinking that the country
thought he was a failure.
So, yes I think that,
the fact that 43 could
help me lift my gaze,
from current crisis and current feelings
and lift my gaze and understand
there's a longer view,
that really helped me
in my life, actually,
over all, not just in politics.
- Yeah, I love that.
Can you talk a little
bit about just generally,
what it's like, sort of working at Fox
and being in the eye of the storm,
where often, you guys are as critiqued
as the politicians you're
supposed to be talking about?
This is a particularly
unique thing to Fox,
where every given day, we
know that Media Matters
is watching you guys,
waiting for you to stumble over some word.
Then they clip that video.
They get it out to Huff
Po, they get it to VOX.
They try to, you know,
they lie about timelines.
Greg's dealing with a
version of this right now,
related to Coronavirus.
How in a weird way, the
stories then become about you,
or that somebody's boycotting
Tucker on any given day.
Just that whole thing.
- So I have a ton of respect for
the media relations department
at Fox News because,
(laughing)
they are dealing with,
they are drinking from a
fire hose, every single day.
And we have strong
personalities, at the network
and we have the freedom to
say what we want to say.
I'm usually pretty,
pretty much left alone.
I guess maybe I don't say anything
that controversial or interesting,
(laughs) for them to bother.
But I don't like it when
someone who is expressing
an opinion and then it gets distorted,
I really can't stand that
and this is an example
that I wanted to mention
that just came to mind.
It doesn't have exactly to do with Fox,
but it's a good example of my experience
of dealing with the media
and you mentioned the Huffington Post.
So, I did the PR for
George W. Bush's memoir,
"Decision Points", when
it came out in 2010.
We're out there, the book is launched.
Going pretty well, although 43, boy,
he had not done interviews in two years
and he was not excited
to see the press again,
I'll tell you that.
- (laughs) I bet.
(laughing)
Well he really,
you know, often presidents
disappear for a little while,
but he sort of, he really
just went under the radar.
Finally, there was that
picture of him painting
and people were like,
- He said that,
- "Oh what happened?"
- Yeah, he said, for a long time he said,
"I don't seek the (mumbles) lights.
"I don't want this attention."
He knew that there was another chapter,
and that he had watched his dad
be such a gracious former president
and that was his role model.
But back to the book tour.
So, we're doing the book
tour and all of a sudden,
I get this email that the
Huffington Post is saying that,
George W. Bush plagiarized
some of his book.
Like, "What is he talking about?"
Because, I knew that he
and a former speech writer
had worked on all of it together.
Like, "What are they talking about?"
So I read it.
I'm like, "Oh my gosh."
So this reporter for Huffington Post
wrote that in Bob Woodward's book,
from like three years ago.
There's a passage in there
in which Bob Woodward,
quotes somebody, who was a
source close to the President,
who said this about the Iraq War.
Therefore, they said that that
(laughing)
that George W. Bush
who had then written that
- I got it.
- In Decision Points, that therefore,
he was plagiarizing Bob Woodward.
I was like, "Obviously, he's the source
"close to the President, is
the President, you dumbass."
Sorry, can we say that on here?
- Hey, you can say
- Okay (laughs).
- Anything here, come on now
(laughs).
- I remember how mad I was.
It just so happened that
the publisher of the book
was also the publisher of
Arianna Huffington's books.
So, I was getting nowhere with
the reporter to take it down.
So she said that she would
call and get her to handle it.
Do you know, they would not take it down?
And, so I'm not a
stranger to this behavior
in how they treated him
or other conservatives,
or Trump now today.
It's just unfortunate, but you
just have to work around it.
- Yeah, but it must take a certain amount
of your mental stamina during the day,
right, knowing that these guys,
or even when you're just
talking on your show
and you might accidentally say ass
and then you go, "Uh-oh,
"now what have I done?"
- Oh yeah like that time
that I said that the guy
carrying the alligator
with his mouth taped in
the convenience store.
It was during one more thing
and I said, "What an asshole."
(laughing)
And oh my gosh,
and that's unusual for me.
And it caused such an uproar,
but we turned it into something funny
and actually, the president of the company
got a call from his mom and she said,
"Please don't get mad at Dana.
"Don't get her in any trouble.
"She didn't mean to say
it, it was an accident
"and besides, she was right,
the guy was an asshole."
(laughing)
- He was, there you go.
- Florida, man.
- Can you talk
a little bit about the
general culture at Fox?
Because you know, until I started going
on a bunch of these
shows, like a year ago.
I don't know, I probably thought,
whatever maybe the
mainstream zeitgeist is.
But I know that, you know,
I've been doing your show
basically once a week for awhile now
and I go on Greg and Tucker.
Nobody asks me anything.
You know the first few
times I went on Tucker,
they would say, "Oh do you have some ideas
"that you wanna talk about?"
But now you guys invite me.
I go on, we don't discuss anything.
I know that I could say anything
in those few minutes and
you may not agree with me,
but you'd be okay with
it and we can joke around
and the rest of it.
People will always say to me,
"Well Dave, why don't
you go on CNN and MSNBC?"
I'm like, "Well they don't invite me.
"If they did,
- What's the point?
- "As long as?"
- Oh they don't, yeah.
- Well I guess what's the
point, also, nobody's watching.
But you know, they don't invite me.
I can't just show up.
- Or,
- I actually have
showed up at--
- What's the point
if you think you're
not going to be allowed
to just be yourself and express your views
and have that respected?
- Yeah, but the meme would be,
"Oh Fox News is just pushing out
"talking points to everybody."
But I just know it's not true,
because you guys let
me say whatever I want.
- Yeah, I've been there,
since April of '09.
I've never once been
asked to say something,
press a message, anything.
This has never happened to me,
or to anybody that I know.
I think one of the best things about Fox,
is it's a culture of respecting everybody
as an individual, but working
as a very close knit team.
One thing that people might not know,
is that, Sean Hannity
has been the Papa Bear
of so many careers at Fox, including mine.
When I first left the White House,
you know, he knew that I was interested
in doing a contributor work,
or at least continuing to have,
continuing to be a part
of the conversation.
So he recommended me
and apparently, Roger
Ailes said something like,
"Well why do we need
another Bush Republican,
"we already have Karl Rove."
Sean said, "She's different, trust me,
"let me give her a shot."
And he started inviting
me on his show once a week
and eventually, that's
what led me to my contract
with Fox News and every step of the way,
this man has been so encouraging of me.
Every step of the way.
When The Five started,
he could not have been
more excited for us.
When A Daily Briefing started,
he also is so excited and when I see him
on occasion in the hallways now,
he'll say, "I can't
hear what you're saying,
"because your show is
on during my radio show,
"but I have the closed caption on
"and you look amazing
and your guests are great
"and everything you're saying."
It's like so encouraging.
It's been really
rewarding, in that regard.
I think of a lot of these
people that I work with as,
part of my extended family.
I look forward to seeing them everyday
and it's a wonderful place to be.
I'm glad you asked me about that,
because I don't always reflect on,
on how great it is, actually.
- So the media has been leveled.
What do you think, Dana Perino?
- (laughs) One of the
things about this time,
is I've realized that I can
actually do everything from home.
It's not ideal.
Television and putting
on a television show,
like The Daily Briefing or The Five.
That is a team sport.
Fox is probably the leanest company
I've ever seen or been a part of.
So, there's not a lot of spare capacity.
So, everybody trying to
do things from remote,
it's difficult, but we have done it.
There's never been a moment of dead air.
We are on air all the time.
But this morning I did two podcasts.
One by Zoom, one by Skype.
I have done my shows from here.
What else did I do?
Oh, I wrote an article for Foxnews.com,
about how boredom can actually lead to
great imaginations.
I don't know if--
- Oh yeah!
- When I was a kid, I
wasn't allowed to be bored.
My parents would say,
"Get outside and play.
"You have no excuse
(laughing)
"to be bored."
If you look at like some
of these internet memes.
They're hilarious.
This guy Ian Prior.
He worked at the Justice
Department for awhile.
He took the theme song of Growing Pains
and made a video with his family,
called, "Growing Bored."
But it's to the same music
and with all the video.
It is so good and it's
amazing what people can do,
just from home.
Or anywhere they are.
- Did you know that
Allen Thick wrote.
Did you know that Alan
Thicke wrote that himself
and he also wrote the
theme song to Facts of Life
and a couple others?
- I had no idea.
That's awesome, I love The Facts of Life.
That was a great show.
- Yeah, (laughs), it was a great show.
But what do you think about this,
like just the generally
that now people can
get their news from a
gajillion different things?
You know we went from
decades of 6:30 p.m.,
ABC, CBS, NBC.
- Oh I watched it all, yeah.
- Yeah, but then we went from that.
Then we had cable news.
Now we have cable channels, proliferating.
Then there's also this thing.
The podcast, YouTube, other world
and now, everybody's
competing with everybody.
Like, do you find it hard to figure out
what is true through that whole mess?
- Not really, because
I have trusted sources
that I check and I'm a pretty
well rounded news consumer
and I have a pretty strong
sense of what's real
and what's not and I'm
also, as I mentioned before,
I'm super cautious with my words
and cautious with saying anything
before I know for sure it's a go.
One of my great fears for
The Daily Briefing is,
being one of the first
people in broadcast news to
put out one of those deep fake videos,
thinking that it's real.
So I think it's a time where it's like
crossing a river of crocodiles everyday.
I don't know how it's gonna shake out,
but I also don't wanna be
somebody who longs for the past.
I'm excited about all of
these great technologies.
Fox I think has been really smart
in trying to figure out a way to
deliver product for our consumers,
that are still cable subscribers.
But also, during this time of Coronavirus,
they took down the paywall
for the Fox News app.
So anybody that wants to watch Fox News,
can do it on the app and
then I think they can
capture new viewers,
whether that be on our
Facebook channel, or sorry,
the Facebook page or the YouTube channel.
You know I started this thing called,
"Storytime with Dana", right
when the Coronavirus started
and everyday at 3:30
I read a book to kids.
I just started doing it on Facebook Live,
but Fox loved it so much that they took it
and now they have it on Fox Nation,
which is a streaming service,
FoxNews.com, the YouTube
channel, Facebook and Twitter,
we get it all around.
So, it's a lot of experimentation.
It'll be fun to see where it all leads.
- Yeah, so I know you're not a spokesman
for the conservative movement, as a whole.
(laughing)
But do you think
conservatives maybe had
some branding issues,
over the years that,
- Sure.
- I think are actually,
I think actually are
melting away right now.
I mean I think I'm
probably evidence of it,
you know, when I go and
you guys are all nice to me
and I can talk and debate
and all that good stuff.
But that for a long time,
maybe just the word conservative,
it sounds kind of stogy and old
and it's like why would a young person
wanna be conservative?
That actually, some of that's
actually changing right now?
- Absolutely.
But everything cycles through the decades.
You know National Review for me,
my dad I think was a subscriber
since I was a little kid.
I think he voted for Goldwater,
I believe that's right.
So I just grew up in
that world, on a ranch.
You know, individual
responsibility and state's rights,
that was super important to all of us.
But certainly things have changed.
For example, I think
conservatives for a long time,
were considered people who were against
the gay rights movement.
Who were against gay marriage.
Over time, and not that long of a time,
if you think about in history.
That melted away.
So that I think, allowed for people to
give conservatism a different look,
but part of that is, what
are you comparing it to?
If you are finding that
you are out of sorts with
some of the nonsense on the left,
then you might take another
look at conservatism
and you look at somebody
like Dan Crenshaw,
the Congressman from Texas.
I did his podcast this morning.
He's a younger, different
kind of conservative.
Then you see him on Saturday Night Live,
responding with grace and
humor to Pete Davidson,
who had so casually attacked
him, mocking his war injury.
So there's a lot of great
opportunity for conservatives.
But, you know, it's a challenge,
especially as you might imagine,
there's all these different
ways to communicate now.
So how do you get to your ideas,
to be persuasive for a
larger amount of people,
especially younger people.
That's a challenge.
But I think it's going better than
some in the media might think it is.
- Huh, interesting.
All right, now I'm gonna ask you to put
the press secretary cap on, so.
- Okay.
- I'll give you two things here.
One, if you were Trump's press secretary,
would you want more responsibility
and want him to reign it in a little bit?
And two, if you were
Biden's press secretary,
would you want him doing
these live streams,
(laughing)
that are in my
humble opinion, coming
off pretty terribly?
- I think if I were
Trump's press secretary,
the one thing I would not wanna be,
is blindsided and surprised.
That's why I would never
be Trump's (laughs)
press secretary.
But I already had that job.
(laughing)
They're never gonna ask me, but,
you know, I think that
it's incredibly difficult
to think about knowing
an answer at 11 o'clock,
giving that answer at 12 o'clock
and having it undermined at 12:06 p.m.
But that is how he operates.
Some people love it, some
people think it's horrible.
The Biden question is a
little bit more difficult.
I don't know what I would do.
They're in a real fix right now,
because, Joe Biden is now
the presumptive nominee.
He's gotten no bang for that buck,
after Bernie Sanders dropped out.
Everybody's sort of like, "Yeah, okay."
Then Biden says, "I'm
gonna start my VP search."
And we're like, "Oh okay,
well there's about 10 women
"that you might consider, so oh well."
I mean people are just so zeroed in on,
appropriately so, the health of the nation
and the economic health of the nation.
I think that if Biden were to come out
and push too hard against
President Trump right now
and criticize, the Commander
in Chief in the time of
a major, not just a domestic
crisis, a global crisis,
it would look like he
was rooting for failure
for the country.
So he's gotta pick his spots
very carefully and sharply.
I just don't know if he's
gonna be able to do that.
- Do you sense though
that some in the media,
are rooting for the
collapse of the economy
and just that they view this as,
"Oh we didn't get Trump on Russia.
"We didn't get Trump
on Ukraine impeachment,
"blah, blah, blah."
- I don't think so.
No.
- That this,
you don't think so, huh?
- No, I don't.
I don't, I mean I consume a ton of news.
I'm not naive to the biases,
but, there's a lot of problems out there.
I mean, like the Food Lions.
It's just the video, you
can see from overhead,
a three mile long car
line, to get food in Miami.
A six mile long car line
to get food in San Antonio.
I mean those are just facts.
Those are happening.
I don't think that they
root for the failure.
They might root for
President Trump to lose.
But I don't think that
they root for failure,
for people, I really don't.
- Yeah, I hope you're right.
I mean I see some people that
are pretty mainstream voices,
that it's almost like
they just want this thing
to continue, you know,
maybe--
- Well I mean that
was true like during the
financial crisis of 2008, right?
They were like, "Oh now Bush."
But it was like, well,
if you didn't shore up the banks
and you ended up with something worse
than the Great Depression,
what would've been the better choice?
Again, presidents can't worry about that.
President Trump has to,
again, lift his gaze
and not worry about the
headline of the day.
Lift his gaze, look out.
People are gonna judge this
for years and years and years.
Forget about what they're gonna say
within the next 24 hours.
Are you making the best decisions,
with the information you have at the time,
on behalf of the nation and
can you defend that decision?
Then that's the decision you should make,
you should defend it as much as you can
and promote it, whatever you need to do.
But I wouldn't get so mired in,
"Oh, they're against me."
Because, I think self pity in politics
is pretty pathetic and pitiful.
You just need to win, you
just have to try harder
to win the arguments.
It just takes a lot more effort.
That's why I always tell companies,
"If you think you're
gonna have some problems,
"always hire somebody that's worked in
"Republican politics or communications,
(laughing)
"because, guaranteed,
"they've had to work harder."
- They've been through it once or twice.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, do you think that Trump though,
sort of needs that in a way?
Like it's almost like him and Jim Acosta,
are just like a match made
in Hell, sort of thing.
Like, CNN needs it for eyeballs
and Trump needs it, because that's like,
sort of what gives him juice.
So they're playing
this game
- It's a symbiotic
relationship,
- but if anything.
Yeah, yeah.
- Yep the symbiotic
relationship, they feed off of each other.
But I was watching a
press conference recently
and I heard myself saying,
"That's a ridiculous question.
"That's a dumb question."
But, look, our founding fathers were
really, really brilliant
and the First Amendment
was first for a reason.
Because it's most important.
So we have to safe guard
it and if they wanna
ask stupid questions, that's, so be it.
- All right, I got two more for you
and then I know you gotta go do The Five.
'Cause you do have a day job too.
- I do.
- So one,
I've been joking for about two years,
people always say to
me, "Dave do you want,
"are you gonna get into politics?"
And I always say, "No, but if Ben Shapiro
"becomes president, I will
be his press secretary."
Is that a crazy
- Great!
- Thing for me to say?
Do you think that's a crazy thing?
- I've never said this out loud.
But I told Ben Shapiro
if he becomes president,
I would come be his
Chief of Staff (laughs).
(laughing)
- Well I would be
thrilled to work with you,
so maybe we are putting
the pieces together here.
- This could come back to
bite us both, you know?
- Oh man.
- We're gonna be
in those jobs in the soup (laughs).
- Oh, just when see you
thought you were gonna get out
(laughing)
and they pull you
right back in.
- That's so funny, I
never said that out loud.
But it's true.
- All right, so that aside.
Now, really the most important thing.
Where is Jasper and tell us about Jasper
and let's see Jasper.
- So Jasper is eight years old.
He's here, Jasper, hey.
Can you come here?
Come, come.
- Clyde always gets shy
when I'm on your show.
- Come, come now.
- So let's see if
- I know.
- Jasper can show him up
a little bit.
- So Jasper has been
on TV a lot since he was,
come on, since he was a kid.
Since he was born.
Come up, up, say hi to your people.
Come on, up.
There we go.
This is Jasper.
- [Dave] Oh, look at this.
- There you go.
- Look, wait!
(laughing)
What, now you're
not gonna do it?
Come on!
(slapping)
Look at Jasper, he's gorgeous.
- Clyde!
- He's eight years old.
- Look at how he looks
at the camera.
- Come on, Clyde,
what are you doing?
- He even knows we're,
oh, here's Clyde.
(laughing)
- Yeah, Clyde's, lazy.
Come on!
There we go, all right.
We're half way there.
- You know,
you know one of the thing's I found, Dave,
is that, no come stay.
That dogs are a great equalizer.
There's no politics at
the dog park for me.
We all love our dogs.
(kissing) and they give us a lot of joy.
You know, whatever love you give them,
you get back five times in return.
I'm so, so glad that you two
plunged back in and rescued Clyde.
It makes me happy for
you and your household
and for Clyde, in particular.
- I told you, literally, I had him like,
it was like the second day I had him
and I'm walking him down the street
and this guy, my neighbor for years,
who I've seen for years,
but never said hello to, he goes,
"Oh, that's Clyde.
"I just saw him on Dana Perino's show."
So.
(laughing)
We're making the world a better place,
there you go.
- I love that.
I love that.
I really have loved
- All right, Dana
- Getting to know you.
- Yeah, same here.
Well thanks for doing
good work in the midst
of this craziness and showing people
that you can be human
and still like politics
and taking good care of Jasper.
So have a great day.
(upbeat music)
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos, be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.